Vítej zpět v seriálu Kvantové výpočetnictví v praxi. Tato epizoda se zaměří na první a často nejobtížnější
krok při definování kvantového programu – mapování obecného problému na circuit, který může běžet na kvantovém
počítači. Tento krok popisuje, jak uživatel začínající s daným výpočetním
problémem ho může přeložit tak, aby mu kvantový počítač rozuměl.
V předchozích lekcích této série – lekcích dvě a tři – jsme diskutovali o tom, že fáze mapování je první ze
čtyř kroků v rámci Qiskit patterns. Z těchto lekcí si možná pamatuješ, že naším cílem bylo přeložit
nebo přepsat výpočetní problém do podoby účelové funkce nebo střední hodnoty,
kterou můžeme vyhodnotit pomocí kvantového počítače.
V lekci tři jsme diskutovali o jednom konkrétním příkladu s max cut – problémem,
který je výpočetně náročný a je běžný v kombinatorické optimalizaci.
V tom příkladu jsme prošli několika kroky k transformaci původního grafu na kvantově nativní problém. Přeložili jsme
problém hledání maximálního počtu řezů v grafu do účelové funkce, poté tuto účelovou funkci
přepsali jako Hamiltonián a připravili zkušební kvantový stav, jehož základní stav
odpovídá max cut. Nakonec jsme zkonstruovali kvantový circuit reprezentující zkušební kvantový stav
zájmu a přidali konkrétní gate, které umožňují stavu vyvíjet se v čase. Tato sekvence kroků je to, čemu
říkáme mapování. A na vysoké úrovni je tento postup obecný pro mnoho dalších aplikací, jako je kvantová chemie
a kvantová simulace. Nelze se vyhnout faktu, že mapování může být obtížné. Neexistuje
univerzální strategie pro každý jednotlivý problém, takže to může být odstrašující. Dnes zdůrazním
reprezentativní příklady různých problémů a popíšu, jak byly v každém případě namapovány. Rychle
zopakuji, co jsme se naučili o grafových problémech, jako jsou ty použité v Max Cut, a zbytek přednášky věnuji
tomu, jak mapovat problémy, které se vyskytují v přírodě – jako jsou problémy molekulární struktury v biologii, elektronické
struktury v chemii a simulace kvantových teorií pole ve fyzice vysokých energií.
Ale než strávíme většinu času v této epizodě studiem příkladů z literatury, chci ti poskytnout
přehled hlavních věcí, které chceme splnit a zvážit při mapování problému. Existuje
několik věcí, které je třeba zvážit pro jakýkoli typ výpočetního problému, který bude potřeba přeložit do kvantového circuit.
Za prvé, možná budeš muset problém zjednodušit, aby byl řešitelný. To je něco běžného ve většině vědeckých
disciplín – není to specifické pro kvantové výpočetnictví. Pokud jsi někdy slyšel výraz „předpokládej
kulovou krávu", odkazuje na fakt, že je často těžké popsat systém přesně tak, jak vypadá. Ale
místo toho můžeme provést rozumná zjednodušení, která stále mohou vést k užitečným řešením.
Některé příklady toho, jak bychom to mohli dělat v kvantovém výpočetnictví, jsou omezení velikosti nebo hloubky circuit výběrem
hardwarově efektivního ansatz nebo zkrácením složitých časových evolucí nebo zanedbáním
členů Hamiltoniánu, které málo přispívají k výsledné energii kvantového stavu.
Dalším bodem, který chci zdůraznit, je, že budeš muset přemýšlet o tom, jak problém zapsat tak, aby mu kvantový počítač rozuměl.
Často to zahrnuje zodpovězení těchto tří otázek. Za prvé, co budou naše qubitů
reprezentovat v tomto modelu? Za druhé, je náš problém spojitý? Protože kvantové počítače jsou digitální, budeš muset
najít způsob, jak problém diskretizovat. A za třetí, odpovídá topologie problému topologii
hardwaru? Pokud ano, skvěle. Pokud ne, možná budeme muset implementovat některé triky, aby to fungovalo. Tak se podívejme na
tuto první otázku – to, co považuji za jádro všech obtíží s pochopením mapování, zejména jako
nového konceptu. Co může qubit reprezentovat?
Qubitů lze použít k reprezentaci mnoha věcí. Nejprve a nejjednodušeji – podle mého názoru – je uzel v grafu. Grafy se
používají k zobrazení konektivity a mnoha různých typů matematických problémů. A uzly jsou základním prvkem reprezentujícím bod
nebo entitu v rámci sítě. V závislosti na tom, co celá síť představuje, to může být město, osoba nebo
feromagnet v mřížce. Qubitů lze také použít k reprezentaci bozonů a fermionů. Upozorním zde ale,
že jeden qubit se přesně nerovná jednomu bozonu nebo jednomu fermionu. Je to trochu
složitější a brzy to vysvětlím, ale obecně řetězec spinů, který se řídí určitou statistikou, je
něco, co lze snadno přeložit na architekturu qubitů.
Nyní se dostáváme k příkladům, které jsou o trochu složitější. Pro tyto modely již nedává smysl
mluvit v termínech jednoho qubitů.
Místo toho potřebujeme jejich skupiny, aby tvořily něco fyzického. Například
skupina qubitů zde reprezentovaná na topologii těžkého šestiúhelníku může být použita k reprezentaci geometrických poloh aminokyselin
nebo polymerních řetězců. Dalším příkladem je simulace rozptylu hadronů
v modelech fyziky vysokých energií, která může být provedena simulací časové evoluce hadronového vlnového balíku. V tomto případě
může registr qubitů být použit ke kódování různých stavů kvantového pole – vakuového stavu tohoto pole nebo
vlnového balíku, který se šíří na tomto vakuu.
Také chci poznamenat, že mapování problému na kvantový počítač má odlišné kroky: za prvé mapování
stavů na qubitů a circuit a za druhé mapování účelové funkce nebo střední hodnoty
kvantových observabilů a operátorů. Uvidíme, jak jsou tyto kroky zvládány v konkrétních příkladech. Ale
v tuto chvíli jsme hovořili dostatečně abstraktně o výzvě, která před námi leží.
Pojďme se nyní podrobně podívat na tyto příklady.
Začněme naším prvním příkladem. Podle mého názoru je jedním z nejsnazších problémů mapování ten, který jsme již
do určité hloubky probrali – příklad max cut. V tom problému bylo mapování pro nás poměrně snadné, protože jeden qubit
WEBVTT
se rovnal jednomu uzlu v našem grafu. Použití uzlů v grafu je velmi intuitivní, a to je naštěstí tak,
protože to odpovídá mnoha aplikacím. Mnohokrát, když chceš modelovat něco, co odpovídá
sérii uzlů spojených dohromady, pokud jsou skupiny binární – jako nula nebo jedna nebo zahrnuté a nezahrnuté do
sady – můžeš jednoduše a přirozeně mapovat tyto uzly na bity nebo qubitů.
V tomto příkladu, a dokonce i v tom, který jsme v epizodě 3 rozšířili na 100 qubitů, konektivita grafu
již odpovídala topologii našeho supravodivého hardwaru. Takže jsme se tím nemuseli zabývat ani. To ale není vždy případ.
A pokud máš složitější nebo více propojený graf než příklady, které jsme zatím zdůraznili, budeš
muset implementovat swap gate. Ale toto je ve skutečnosti řešeno ve druhém kroku Qiskit patterns, který se zabývá
transpilací. Další část problému max cut, která ho činí tak praktickým, je, že
již víme, jak vyjádřit účelovou funkci jako Hamiltonián pomocí formulace QUBO.
Připomeňme, že v kvantovém výpočetnictví a variačních kvantových algoritmech je Hamiltonián účelová funkce funkce,
která kóduje optimální řešení problému v základním stavu Hamiltoniánu.
Pro konstrukci Hamiltoniánu nákladů jsme mohli použít třídu SparsePauliOp v Qiskit k zadání
konektivity našeho grafu a fáze mapování na kvantové operátory je hotova. A kvantový circuit byl
jednoduše QAOA ansatz. Pokud ti to nic neříká, prosím vrať se a podívej se na epizodu 3, kde to probíráme
mnohem podrobněji. Nyní obtížnost lehce zvýšíme. Dál se podíváme
na příklad modelovaný v článku nazvaném „Resource-efficient quantum algorithm for protein folding" (Algoritmus pro skládání proteinů efektivní z hlediska zdrojů), napsaném
IBM ve spolupráci s University of New South Wales. Trochu biochemického pozadí – proteiny jsou
makromolekuly složené z dlouhých řetězců aminokyselin. Tyto dlouhé řetězce se skládají
do složitých struktur, které vykonávají širokou škálu biologických funkcí.
Určení struktury proteinu v trojrozměrném prostoru a pochopení vztahů mezi
strukturou a funkcí patří k nejobtížnějším problémům v biochemii dnes.
Proteiny se skládají do užitečných struktur kvůli interakcím mezi samotnými aminokyselinami.
Jak se struktura kroutí a skládá, aminokyseliny, které jsou na řetězci daleko od sebe, mohou skončit hned vedle
sebe a mohou silně interagovat. Potřebujeme Hamiltonián popisující všechny tyto interakce mezi aminokyselinami,
pokud chceme předpovědět, jaká výsledná struktura minimalizuje energii. Zde se zaměříme na řetězce aminokyselin a
na to, jak je lze modelovat na kvantovém počítači, a jak pak můžeme získat vzdálenosti mezi aminokyselinami pro
výpočet interakčních energií.
Tím jsme ve skutečnosti shromáždili všechny nezbytné příspěvky k Hamiltoniánu, abychom ho mohli simulovat
na kvantovém počítači. V reálných proteinech mohou aminokyseliny zaujmout kontinuum možných poloh.
My zde ale použijeme zjednodušení a omezíme je na mřížkový model, kde každá aminokyselina
zaujímá bod na mřížce. Autoři zde použili tetraedrickou mřížku.
Rychlá poznámka – kódujeme zde směr hran, nikoli samotné uzly jako v problému max cut.
Každý qubit představuje možnou cestu jednoho kroku podél tetraedrické mřížky. Všimni si, že sousední místa jsou
v tomto diagramu označena jako A nebo B kvůli jejich různé orientaci v mřížce.
Proteinový řetězec je reprezentován jako série zatáček nebo směrů na této
mřížce. Každá zatáčka mezi aminokyselinami může být v jednom ze čtyř směrů,
odpovídajících hranám tetraedru.
Těchto čtyři možné zatáčky jsou kódovány pomocí čtyř qubitů.
To zní trochu složitě. Pojďme se tedy podívat na tento příklad trochu podrobněji.
Umístíme náš první řetězec aminokyselin do tohoto bodu v tetraedrické mřížce. Směr k prvnímu
řetězci aminokyselin k druhému je libovolný, protože systém může být vždy jen otočen tak, aby tato hrana ukazovala
jakýmkoliv směrem, jaký chceme. Umístíme tedy náš druhý řetězec aminokyselin sem. Není to tak
snadno viditelné, ale cesta od druhého ke třetímu je ve skutečnosti také libovolná. Všechny tři volby by
vedly ke dvěma hranám s úhlem přibližně 109,5°
mezi nimi. Výběr této druhé hrany jednoduše určuje orientaci našeho proteinu v prostoru. Takže bez ztráty
obecnosti si můžeme zvolit první zatáčky jako jednoduše 0 0 1 a 0 0 1
0. S těmito zjednodušeními je konfigurace řetězce aminokyselin jednoduše dána tímto výrazem.
Zatím jsme namapovali hrany tetraedru na qubitů a náš kvantový circuit bude ansatz. Nyní potřebujeme
zvážit, jak zakódovat energii problému do Hamiltoniánu, aby jeho základní stav nám dal optimální
vzorec skládání. Pro jakoukoli danou konfiguraci bude existovat přidružená energie kvůli
interakcím mezi samotnými aminokyselinami. Tyto interakce jsou nejsilnější, když jsou dvě aminokyseliny
blízko sebe. Samozřejmě aminokyseliny sousedící v páteři řetězce budou vždy interagovat
mezi sebou. Ale protože se protein může kroutit a skládat, jiné páry aminokyselin
mohou také interagovat. Aminokyseliny 10 a 20 například mohou skončit na
sousedních místech poté, co se protein složil. Aminokyseliny, které skončí blízko sebe, mají silnější
interakce a řídí proces skládání, ale nemusí nutně mít indexy, které jsou blízko
sebe. Potřebujeme tedy vzorec pro popis vzdálenosti D mezi aminokyselinami I a
J pomocí informací zakódovaných na konfiguračních qubitech. Tak můžeme
použít jejich vzdálenost oddělení k určení síly jejich interakce. To je trochu složité,
ale vydržte, protože je to šikovný trik. Nejprve zavedeme funkci f sub a pro i, která indikuje, zda
WEBVTT
hrana a je použita pro zatáčku u aminokyseliny i. Zde může a nabývat jakéhokoli
ze čtyř možných směrů s ohledem na kódování konfigurace výše. Tyto funkce pak můžeme zapsat a
definovat rozdíl v počtu zatáček označených a na mřížkách A a B od
indexu I do indexu J jako delta N. Proč bychom to dělali? No, ukazuje se, že
tetraedrická mřížka má velmi užitečnou vlastnost. Zaměřme se na tuto aminokyselinu tady. Nezáleží na tom, která to je,
ale říkejme jí aminokyselina E. Chceme vědět, jak daleko bude aminokyselina j. A vše, co máme,
jsou hrany, po kterých kroky páteře vedou. Počínaje I si všimni, že krok ven
ze středu podél určitého typu hrany – říkejme mu a – z tohoto místa mřížky a
je přesně opačný a je anulován krokem ven podél hrany a z
míst b. Takže více kroků podél hrany A z jakéhokoli místa mřížky A přesouvá
páteř od aminokyseliny E a kroky podél typu hrany A z míst B
tě přivádějí zpět. Takže vzdálenost mezi dvěma aminokyselinami I a J podél hrany
typu, který označíme A, závisí na rozdílu mezi kroky provedenými podél A
hran z míst A a míst B. Protože A a B se v proteinové páteři nutně střídají,
je to zachyceno členem (-1) na K. A tento argument platí i pro jiné typy hran.
Vzdálenost mezi aminokyselinami v krocích tetraedrické mřížky lze tedy nakonec vypočítat tímto
výrazem. Ale jak z této dlouhé rovnice pro celkovou vzdálenost mezi aminokyselinami dostaneme Hamiltonián?
Existuje ve skutečnosti korespondence jedna ku jedné mezi těmito vzdálenostmi v krocích tetraedrické mřížky a euklidovskou
vzdáleností. A vidíš, že jsem pro tebe již vypočítala některé výrazy.
Tyto vzdálenosti lze použít při výpočtu energie tvé konfigurace.
V závislosti na tvém účelu bys mohl určit mezní vzdálenost, pod níž považuješ pár za interagující,
nebo bys mohl udělat něco složitějšího. Možná to není zřejmé, ale tímto jsme vlastně skončili s fází mapování.
Stavy qubitů indikují zatáčku a soubor zatáček určuje vzdálenost mezi libovolným párem aminokyselin.
Páry různých druhů aminokyselin mají různé interakce – některé přitažlivé, jiné odpudivé.
Pokud používáš konfiguraci a vzdálenost pouze k určení, zda jsou interakce známých aminokyselin zapnuty nebo vypnuty,
jejich síly jsou dobře známy – ne mně, ale můžeš si je vyhledat v tabulce, jako je tato.
Takže shrnuto, v tomto příkladu jsou qubitů použity k označení poloh v mřížce, které dohromady tvoří řetězec aminokyselin.
A simulací toho, jak se ohýbají a skládají, doufejme najdeme lepší výsledky v lékařském výzkumu. Nyní jsme
přeskočili, jak vypočítat několik členů tohoto Hamiltoniánu, protože byly specifické pro tento problém. Zatímco definování
směrů v mřížce lze aplikovat obecněji.
Jakmile máš obecný Hamiltonián, vždy ho budeš chtít přeložit na Pauliho operátory,
které jsou nativní pro kvantový počítač. O tom si povíme dál.
Pokračujeme dál.
Nyní se podívejme, jak přeložit systém subatomárních částic na Pauliho operátory. Subatomární
částice se dělí do dvou kategorií: bozony a fermiony. Bozony
jako fotony nebo Higgsův boson se řídí určitou sadou statistických pravidel a fermiony jako elektrony nebo neutrina se řídí jinou.
Klíčový rozdíl mezi nimi je, že bozony mohou obsazovat stejný stav – neexistuje žádný limit pro to, kolik
bozonů může být v základním stavu nebo v jakémkoli jiném excitovaném stavu. Fermiony jsou naproti tomu sobecké – vyžadují,
aby každá jednotlivá částice měla svůj vlastní kvantový stav. Bozony také mají celočíselné spiny, zatímco fermiony mají poloceločíselné
spiny jako spin 1/2 elektronu nebo exotičtější částice se spinem 3/2. Pro
popis systému částic potřebujeme popis jejich energie. Zaměřme se na fermiony. Můžeme začít s
Hamiltonián napsaným v termínech toho, čemu říkáme operátory c. Jedná se v zásadě o matematické objekty, které
odpovídají vytvoření nebo zániku fermionu ze stavu v systému.
Ty jsou často psány jako fi dagger a fi v notaci, které říkáme druhá
kvantizace. Fi dagger je operátor, který vytváří fermion ve stavu i. Fi je
operátor, který ničí fermion ve stavu i. Ale pamatuj, kvantové počítače obvykle pracují v
bázi qubitů se specifickými pravidly pro reprezentaci fermionických systémů. Přirozeně nepracují v jazyce
fermionických operátorů. Abychom překonali tuto propast, potřebujeme mapovat druho-kvantizovanou notaci na Pauliho operátory,
které přirozeně odpovídají kvantovým gate.
Existuje několik takových transformací pro fermiony. Běžnou volbou je Jordanův-Wignerův transformace.
Mappingy Bravyi-Kitaev a parity jsou novější pro fermionická kódování.
Bozonické operace na druhé straně lze transformovat pomocí Holsteinovy-Primakoffovy transformace nebo přímým
mapováním Fockových stavů na podbázi dostupných bozonických módů.
A pro bozony existují i další možnosti. Ostatní kódování jsou také aktivně zkoumána. Ale nyní se
zaměříme pouze na Jordanovu-Wignerovu transformaci.
Proč tedy jednoduše nepřiřadíme jeden qubit k reprezentaci každého elektronu? No, nemůžeme.
Qubitů jsou rozlišitelné a elektrony nejsou. Například qubitů na jakémkoli zařízení můžeme snadno označit a identifikovat,
ale nerozlišitelnost elektronů znamená, že je nemůžeme vůbec označit. Místo toho musíme ve skutečnosti označovat
operátory podle obsazených orbitalů jako 1s, 2s a 2p
místo konkrétních elektronů. Takže ve skutečnosti musíme označovat operátory podle obsazených orbitalů jako 1s
2s a 2p místo označování konkrétních elektronů. Každý qubit tedy hraje
WEBVTT
přibližně roli orbitalu v molekule, který je buď obsazen, nebo neobsazen.
Ale jak to děláme, je trochu složitější. Zavedeme tedy něco, co se nazývá Jordanova-Wignerova transformace, abychom sledovali
antisymetrii a zajistili dodržování správné statistiky celkového fermionického systému. Jordanova-
Wignerova transformace je konceptuálně jednoduchá díky korelaci jedna ku jedné mezi orbitaly a qubitů. Existují
i jiná mapování, která splňují podobný cíl, včetně mapování parity.
Výpočet parity stavu vyžaduje uvažovat více qubitů. V mapování parity a některých dalších platí interpretace
jednoho qubitů odpovídajícího jednomu orbitalu neplatí.
Nyní si projdeme poměrně jednoduchý příklad, abychom se ujistili, že tuto transformaci zvládáme.
Řekněme, že chceme vypočítat jednoqubitovou interakci f dagger f. Začneme dosazením našich definic pro
operátory zvyšování a snižování. Pak můžeme seskupit členy s faktorizací jednotkové matice I a 1/4.
Jak vidíme, zůstanou nám členy, které budou povědomé těm, kdo se zabývají komutačními relacemi. Tento člen zde v
závorce není nic jiného než i krát komutátor X a Y. A
nezapomeň na identitu, kterou jsme vytáhli ven.
Pamatuj, že jsou to jen Pauliho matice. Komutátor je tedy dobře znám. Komutátor X a Y v
tomto pořadí je jednoduchý – je to 2iZ. Dávej pozor, abys neztratil záporná znaménka, a dostaneš toto jako svůj výsledek.
Na konci jsme úspěšně přepsali fermionický výraz
v termínech Pauliho operátorů, kterým náš kvantový počítač bude rozumět.
Pojďme si rychle probrat, jak bychom implementovali Jordanovu-Wignerovu transformaci v Qiskit, protože i když si myslím, že je
důležité rozumět tomu, jak tato transformace a podobné fungují, a vidět ji alespoň jednou propracovanou,
nechtěl bys muset dělat všechny tyto výpočty ručně pokaždé.
Zejména pro systémy velké velikosti – konkrétně – můžeme využít funkci SparsePauliOp v Qiskit k
snadnému vytvoření přidružených Pauliho operací z mapování. Neoptimální
implementace využívá vnořené smyčky a zabere asi 20 řádků kódu.
Odkaz na kód ti přiložím k prozkoumání. Ale na vysoké úrovni jsou kroky následující.
Za prvé, použij funkci SparsePauliOp.from_list k vytvoření operátoru identity
odpovídajícího velikosti parametrového prostoru, který má být mapován. Za druhé, v souladu s definicí
operátorů vytváření a anihilace ukázaných dříve, použij funkci SparsePauliOp.from_list k definování X, Y a Z Pauliho
operací. Tím se namapují fermionické operátory vytváření a anihilace na qubitové spinové operátory kódující fermionické
obsazovací číslo do výpočetní báze qubitů. A za třetí, vygeneruj požadovaný
Hamiltonián v Pauliho bázi aplikací výše uvedených operátorů na orbitaly zájmu. To obvykle odpovídá
vytvoření matice identity, která reprezentuje jádro – neinteragující orbitaly – a pak aplikaci
operátorů vytváření a anihilace na aktivní prostor s váhami, které odpovídají specifice problému. Jak
jsem zmínila, jde jen o přehled na vysoké úrovni. Kód není příliš složitý, a nyní bys se
měl cítit jistě při jeho přizpůsobení jiným problémům zájmu.
Nyní, když plně rozumíme schématu Jordanova-Wignerova mapování, podívejme se na něj v akci ve složitějším nastavení.
Možná si vzpomeneš na tento článek z předchozí epizody – o hadronové dynamice. Nebudu ten článek znovu procházet do hloubky, ale prosím podívej se
na předchozí epizodu, pokud jsi ji zmeškal a jsi zvědavý. V tomto příkladu se Jordanovo-Wignerovo mapování používá k
vyjádření Hamiltoniánu mřížkových míst s L místy pro Schwingerův model v nepřítomnosti elektrického pole. Zde je
mnohem těžší přesně určit, co jeden qubit reprezentuje v tomto modelu, protože jen
soubor qubitů dohromady tvoří něco fyzického – v tomto kontextu vlnový balík. Místo toho si qubitů můžeš zhruba
představit jako diskretizované části prostoru, kde L je objem mřížky, v níž každý prvek nebo
jednotková buňka zahrnuje dva qubitů. Fermionické operátory, které jsme viděli v předchozím snímku, popisují amplitudu
vlnové funkce na konkrétním místě.
Náš Hamiltonián tedy obsahuje tyto fermionické operátory zvyšování a snižování. Ale pro implementaci takového
Hamiltoniánu na kvantovém počítači ho budeme muset vyjádřit v termínech spinových operátorů, nikoli fermionických operátorů.
Použijeme tedy Jordanovu-Wignerovu transformaci. Po aplikaci Jordanovy-Wignerovy transformace se náš nový
Hamiltonián stane touto rovnicí v dolní části snímku, kde sigma plus je Pauliho operátor X + iY a sigma
minus je X - iY. Jakmile máme Hamiltonián zapsaný v tomto formátu,
nejtěžší část fáze mapování je za námi a lze ho nyní snadno zapsat do circuit v Pauliho operátorech.
Shrneme, diskutovali jsme čtyři příklady toho, jak byly konkrétní techniky mapování nedávno použity v
oblasti kvantového výpočetnictví. Počínaje nejjednodušším a pracující se až k aplikaci Jordanovy-Wignerovy transformace na
hadronovou dynamiku. Uvědomuji si, že je toho hodně. Tento materiál byl velmi technický
a pokud jsi ho dříve neviděl, může být velmi odstrašující. Dobrá zpráva je, že ti slibuji, že to bude snadnější a
povědomější, čím více času strávíš procvičováním. A to je skutečně smysl celé věci a proč jsem celou
sérii pojmenovala Kvantové výpočetnictví v praxi.
To není něco, co by mohl kdokoli jen tak vzít a okamžitě s tím běžet. Vyžaduje to trochu studia, trochu
přemýšlení a pravděpodobně i frustrující chvíle. Ale povzbuzuji vás všechny, abyste zůstali s tím nepohodlím a
skutečně zkoumali otázky, které vyvstanou, jak budete pokračovat – protože to je jediný způsob, jak se skutečně naučit. Díky za
sledování. Toto byla epizoda 5 seriálu Kvantové výpočetnictví v praxi. Příště se podíváme na to, jak simulovat
Hamiltonián od nuly. Uvidíme se brzy.